Okay, I recently watched a hilarious
debate on an Arabic religious program
that once again reminded me of the
importance of the hadith. So, let's have
a quick discussion about it. Cherished
by Muslims for containing the
instructive and edifying words and deeds
of their beloved prophet Muhammad, the
hadith also serves as one of the most
potent weapons, one of the most potent
pmics against Islam. It is in fact a
double-edged sword. So, let's look into
it. Before unpacking this strange irony,
however, a little relevant background.
In an earlier video, I said that
although those Western people who insist
that Muhammad never existed dismiss the
hadith as forgeries, the hadith actually
do lend credence to the existence of an
Arabian prophet, though indirectly. Why
did I say this? Because if they were
later forgeries meant to create a sacred
foundational story for Islam centering
around around a noble and righteous
prophet, why do so many of them present
Muhammad in a very unflattering light?
As does the hadith we will soon be
examining. The most common rebuttal to
this observation appearing in the
comment section of that video, see I do
read them, went as follows. Sir, you
need to understand things that seem
strange to us moderns were normal among
the Arabs of the time. No, I do
understand that. Really, I do. And even
in that previous video had given as an
example the notorious alabir hadith
whereby Muhammad told a woman to
breastfeed a man, that is to thrust her
breast in a grown man's mouth as a way
of making him her son.
[Music]
Brother, what's
that? Considering the conservative,
patriarchic, and hyper tribalism of 7th
century Arabia, trust me when I say that
Muhammad was introducing a radical and
shocking idea even then, which brings me
to my point how the Arabic program I
recently watched validated these two
points. first that the bizarre and
unflattering accounts of Muhammad
contained in the hadith contradict the
idea that the hadith is a later forgery
meant to give Islam a noble foundational
story revolving around a pious and
upright prophet and much more
importantly second that the hadith
because it does capture the essence of
Muhammad remains the chief weapon
against Islam now the debate I watched
centered around a hadith that though
long hidden first started reaching the
general populace of the Arabic speaking
world via satellite programs I'd say
around 2015ish or so. I first wrote an
article about it in 2022. The link in
description. This odd hadith which I'm
about to narrate appears in several
hadith collections including the highly
esteemed musid of nah, founder of one of
Islam's four schools of laws or mib as
well as in many other wellrespected
Islamic texts. All of which are being
taught in Alhar and all of which I have
listed volume and page numbers in the
description of this video. The hadith
which is narrated by Abdullahbah bin
Masoud, a companion of the prophet and
one of Islam's most reliable and
trustworthy transmitters of a hadith
goes as follows. Brace yourself.
Abdullah begins by telling us that
Muhammad called on him to accompany him
on a trip into the desert. When they
reached a certain place and night had
fallen, Muhammad made a line in the
sand, most likely a circle, and told
Abdullah, quote, "Stay behind this line
and do not cross it, for if you do, you
will die." Muhammad then left his
startled companion and walked into the
desert night about the distance of a
hurled stone, says Abdullah. Before
long, our narrator saw a group of men.
He does not specify how many who quote
appeared to be alut. He describes them
as quote tall, lean, and naked. Other
Islamic sources say the Zut were a
black-skinned people, and we'll get into
that later. After describing them,
Abdullah goes on, and here's the
problematic part, to say, quote, "They
went to and began to ride the prophet of
Allah." Literally, that's what the
Arabic says. These tall, black, naked
men rode Muhammad, the Arabic word
yakaboon, which I will presently
discuss, can also be translated as
mounted. And they did this all night
long, says Abdullah. during which time
they would also come and circle around
and try to reach him, but they were
prevented apparently from the line of
protection Muhammad had drawn in the
sand for his companion. Abdullah
concludes his narration, quote, I was
extremely terrified by them, so I sat
down. With the coming of dawn, they
began to depart. Then the prophet of
Allah returned slowly and in pain from
that which they did while riding him.
According to another narration found in
several Islamic texts, including Akbar
Mecca by Alkahi, Muhammad complained to
Abdullah that quote, "They wounded me
all night long." At which point, the
prophet proceeds to lay his head and
fall asleep in Abdullah's lap. Needless
to say, the highly unflattering
implications of this hadith are clear,
but it becomes even more scandalous once
one brings in what several other Islamic
reference books and histories say. For
starters, who are these al- Zut? These
naked men who rode with Muhammad all
night long. According to Islam's written
records, they were a migrant people from
India or modern-day Pakistan. Described
in the sources as very tall, very
dark-skinned, very lean, strong, and
hearty, and often used for labor
intensive work. In early Arabic
ethnographies and literary works, alz
are also depicted as being very sexual
and viral with very large penises. In
fact, according to one Arabic source,
ship
behaken, meaning their large fallacuses
never go limp and are ever ready. I'm
sorry for the coup language, but this is
what the Islamic texts say verbatim.
Now, let's talk about the Arabic word
translated as ride, as in alz road the
prophet. Not only does it have the same
exact meaning in English, as in to ride
a horse, for example, but it carries the
same slang meaning as in copulating with
a woman. In fact, several Islamic
sources use it literally to mean sex.
For example, while commenting on the
famous hadith also in Muslim where
Muhammad says, quote, "Women, dogs, and
donkeys cancel a man's prayer." Al Kuri,
one of Islam's most celebrated
commentators of the Quran, elaborates by
saying, quote, "A woman may be compared
to a cow, horse, or camel, for all are
ridden." It's also interesting to note
that when Alz began circling and trying
to reach our terrified narrator
Abdullah, his first instinct was to sit
down. Was he trying to hide and protect
that one part of his body which these
naked men were apparently trying to
access that is his bottom by sitting
down? Again, as I think you can see,
this hadith is scandalous. Not the sort
of thing you'd expect people who want to
fabricate an honorable prophet would
make up. nor I can assure you was such a
deed done hidden in the desert night
deemed normal or acceptable among the
Arabs of Muhammad's time. Now during the
debates I've watched over this hadith
others including many former Muslims
regularly make even more troubling
connections. For example, they cite the
well-known hadith where Muhammad is
asked the people of paradise have sex
and his answer yes with a vagina that
never tires and a penis that never
weakens. Hm. The phrase, "A penis that
never weakens," is identical to the
aforementioned description of Alz's
genitalia, suggesting, as many former
Muslims are quick to point out that
Muhammad so enjoyed his night with these
naked black men, that he went on to
secretly enshrine its most notable
aspect, powerful penises that never
weaken or slacken, as a characterization
of paradise, and possibly as an inside
joke with himself.
To sum up, based on numerous Islamic
texts, especially Musnel and El Kurubi
and several other historical and and
ethnographical texts. Again, see this
video's description for references. How
this hadith is understood, especially by
ex-Muslims who cite it as cause for
their apostasy, is as follows. And
before I proceed, please note that the
following summary is not based on my
thoughts or words, but rather the words
of first, as we saw, wellrespected
Muslim texts. And second, those who use
this hadith as a palemic against Islam.
I'm trying to give you an idea of what
is being said and how this hadith is
being presented in these debates that
often flare out between Muslims. All
right, here we go. Muhammad took his
close companion Abdullah into the desert
at night. He warned him to wait behind a
line and went off at a distance,
apparently for a pre-planned rendevu.
Before long, Abdullah saw several naked
men from the people of Elzut appear,
described in the sources as tall, lean,
veriral, and with large penises. These
men then took turns riding or mounting
the prophet all night long. They also
tried to reach him, but Abdullah
immediately sat down, apparently to
protect that one part of his body they
were trying to access. As the sun rose,
these naked men began to depart, even as
Muhammad returned in pain, limping
towards Abdullah and saying how Alz had
injured him. He then lays in his
companion's lap and falls asleep.
Finally, as a reflection of what
Muhammad thought of that night, he went
on to enshrine it as an aspect of
paradise where the quote penis never
weakens end quote. Okay, that's what's
being said and what loud shouting
matches take place over. I've personally
watched several satellite Arabic
language shows where Muslims call in and
ask an expert sheh about this hadith.
Typical responses are that one,
alz two, this occurred during Muhammad's
famous meeting with the jin, known in
Islamic tradition as the night of the
jin when the prophet recited the Quran
to them. And three, it's known that
Abdullahbah bin Masoud was not present
with Muhammad during the night of the
jin. So therefore, this hadith must be
weak and likely fabricated. Such are the
responses against this hadith. As we
have seen, however, and as those who use
this hadith as a pmic against Islam
point out, the earliest references to al
depict them as humans. And dismissing
the hadith as weak on the claim that
Abdullah was not present for the night
of the jin is itself very weak since the
night in question had nothing to do with
the jin. Meaning there is no reason to
doubt the words of Abdullah, a chief and
highly trusted transmitter of hadith. By
the way, I decided to ask chat GBT what
it thought were innocent and non-loaded
questions. And as might be expected, it
answered me honestly enough. First, I
asked it whether alut were humans or
jin. To which it responded, quote, "In
Muslim historical sources, the zut were
consistently described as humans, not
jin. They were portrayed as a real
ethnic group, most often associated with
India or sind, modern-day Pakistan, and
as a migrant labor or military class.
They are also described as a rebellious
and militarily capable people. I then
asked chat GBT to give me a physical
description of alz based on early Arabic
sources and it said quote in literary
and anecdotal texts they are grouped
together with other southern or
dark-kinned people all of whom have the
following traits sexual potency
prominent genitalia and associations
with physical strength and verility.
Anyway, so there you have it. Here is a
perfect example of why the hadith should
not be so quickly dismissed as later
forgeries meant to present an honorable
prophet. And here is a perfect example
of how the hadith is being used as a
powerful weapon against Islam.